jetzt kommen wir zu einem richtigen
Machtwort schluss aus vorbei der Kanzler
hat jetzt mal deutlich auf den Tisch
gehauen und damit ein für alle Mal den
AKW Streit zwischen Robert Habeck und
Christian Lindner beendet drei deutsche
Kraftwerke bleiben bis zum 15 April 2023
am Netz genau so hat es der Kanzler
jetzt entschieden und zwar per
richtlinienkompetenzen richtig deutsches
Wort eine knallharte Klatsche für den
Wirtschaftsminister
so etwas macht ein Kanzler nur einmal
Olaf Scholz hat das AKW Machtwort
gesprochen macht Gebrauch von seiner
Richtlinienkompetenz als Kanzler und
brüskiert somit die Grünen die drei
verbliebenen deutschen Atomkraftwerke
laufen bis ins neue Jahr weiter
längstens bis zum 15 April in einem
Brief an seine Minister erklärt der
Kanzler Zitat es werde die gesetzliche
Grundlage geschaffen um alle drei AKWs
Isa 2 Neckarwestheim 2 und Emsland über
den 31 Dezember 22 hinauslaufen zu
lassen der Kanzler beruft sich auf seine
Richtlinienkompetenz erstmals in der
Ampelkoalition ein Scholz Machtwort mit
knall-effekt
monatelang hatten die ampelparteien
heftig über längere AKW-Laufzeiten
gestritten vor allem Grüne und FDP ein
geheimgipfel von Scholz Habeck und
Lindner am Sonntag endete ergebnislos
die von Scholz getroffene Entscheidung
seien Weg mit dem ich gut arbeiten und
leben kann sagte der Wirtschaftsminister
am Montagabend in den ARD-Tagesthemen
erwerbe dafür dass dieser Weg zu Ende
gegangen wird
dabei ist die Scholz Entscheidung für
die Grünen und Wirtschaftsminister
Harbeck eine Klatsche denn die Grünen
hatten erst auf dem Parteitag am
Wochenende ein Weiterbetrieb des Weilers
Emsland über das Jahr 2022 hinaus
ausgeschlossen doch nur einen Tag nach
dem Ende des Bundesparteitags erklärt
der Kanzler den Grünen Beschluss jetzt
für nichtig drei Kraftwerke sollen bis
2023 weiterlaufen auch Emsland bei der
FDP sorgt die scholzentscheidung für
Jubel die Vernunft setzt sich durch
kommentiert Justizminister Marco
Buschmann das Scholz Machtwort auf
Twitter der befristete Weiterbetrieb
aller drei akw-sorge für mehr
Netzstabilität und niedrigere Preise die
FDP hatte sich sogar für einen
Weiterbetrieb der drei Atomkraftwerke
bis 2024 ausgesprochen doch das Kanzler
macht Wort reicht den Liberalen vorhers
der Union hingegen reicht das Kanzler
Machtwort noch nicht ist das alles fragt
CSU-Chef Markus Söder auf Twitter was
für eine Enttäuschung das Problem ist
nur vertagt und weiter die Gefahr eines
Blackouts im kommenden Jahr bleibt
bestehen
sprechen wir darüber und zwar mit
bildpolitikchef Jan Schäfer Jan guten
morgen an Dich
Richtlinienkompetenz das ist ja wie
gesagt so ein sehr deutsches Wort was
bedeutet das und wie oft kann
kanzlerschals eigentlich diese rote
Karte ziehen ja dieses Wort stammt aus
der Geschäftsordnung der Bundesregierung
ist gleich ganz am Anfang vermerkt und
bedeutet dass am Ende der Bundeskanzler
vorgibt wie die Regierung ja zu
entscheiden hat und was Politik der
Regierung ist ist eigentlich relativ
logisch in dem Fall muss man sagen hat
der Bundeskanzler etwas vorgegeben was
am Ende aber das wird mutmaßlich am
Freitag dieser Woche passieren vom
Bundestag noch beschlossen werden muss
und was hat der Bundeskanzler gestern
wir haben es den Beitrag gerade schon
gesehen dann per Richtlinienkompetenz
angeordnet er möchte dass alle drei
Kernkraftwerke über den Silvestertag
hinaus weiterlaufen bis Mitte April
bisher war es ja so und das muss der
Bundestag jetzt dann auch beschließen
dass die drei Kernkraftwerke zum
Jahreswechsel abgeschaltet werden das
will man an nächste Energiekrise nun
verhindern und deswegen dieses Machtwort
diese Richtlinienkompetenz denn wir
wissen es gab großen Streit zwischen FDP
und Grün in der Frage wie geht es denn
nun weiter ja nun hat sich Markus Söder
ein bisschen enttäuscht gezeigt der hat
getwittert auch so eine Enttäuschung das
Problem ist jetzt nur vertagt ist das so
ist das Problem nur vertagt ja das
Problem ist nur für Tag wir werden uns
abgesehen davon dass wir in dieser Woche
noch viel darüber sprechen werden
sicherlich in wenigen Wochen dass es
meine Prognose spätestens Anfang des
nächsten Jahres erneut darüber
unterhalten wie es denn nun weitergeht
denn klar ist wir brauchen zur
Stromerzeugung derzeit auch viel Gas wir
wissen aber Gas ist knapp und wir wissen
auch dass die Kernkraftwerke zur Zeit
zur Stromproduktion ungefähr sieben bis
acht Prozent beitragen wenn wir also
davon ausgehen dass die Gasspeicher im
Winter weil da viel Gas benutzt wird
über den Winter immer Lehrer werden wir
vielleicht im Februar in einer Situation
sind in der das Gas wirklich sehr sehr
knapp ist dann stellt sich doch ganz
logisch die Frage warum schalten wir
dann gleichzeitig eigentlich noch
Kernkraftwerke ab die CO2-neutral sind
um dann zusätzliches Gas oder auch
vielleicht zusätzlich dreckige Kohle zur
Stromerzeugung zu benutzen das
erschließt sich nicht und entsprechend
groß war der Jubel ja gestern auch bei
der FDP die ja für eine
Laufzeitverlängerung bis 2024 einige
sagen sogar darüber hinaus noch ist die
hoffen natürlich jetzt dass im Winter
Ende des Winters genau eine solche
Situation eintritt und man dann über die
Frage reden wird lassen wir die
Kernkraftwerke noch länger am Netz die
FDP die freut sich die Grünen
insbesondere Robert Habeck mit
Sicherheit nicht trotzdem ist es diese
Klatsche noch einigermaßen gesichtswaren
für ihn
ja ob das jetzt gesichtswand ist das
weiß ich gar nicht also Robert Habeck
steckt da jetzt schon politisch gesehen
extrem in der Klemme man hat das gestern
Abend und den Einspieler haben wir ja
gesehen auch in einem Interview gesehen
dass er gegeben hat er wirkt extrem
zerknirscht er ist sicherlich von den
Grünen noch einer der wenigen der diesen
Kompromiss am ehesten mittragen kann und
wahrscheinlich auch von Anfang an
mittragen wollte es gibt jetzt viel
Überzeugungsarbeit zu leisten es gibt
die anti-akkw Hardliner in der Partei
Jürgen Trittin ja schon gestern direkt
gesagt haben nein nein so geht das nicht
da werden wir jetzt noch viel
diskutieren müssen da ist sicherlich
auch ein bisschen Showtheater dabei
faktum ist trotzdem die Grüne Partei war
bis Sonntagabend oder muss abends
eigentlich sagen bis gestern Abend auf
einem völlig anderen Trip und sich
extrem sicher dass die Kernkraftwerke
mindestens eins zum Ende des Jahres
abgeschaltet wird und dann die anderen
beiden im April abgeschaltet werden
dieses dieses diese Gewissheit die ist
seit gestern Abend komplett dahin und
das treibt die Grünen halt auch extrem
um und ist deswegen als politische
Klatsche für Robert Habeck und die
Partei zu deuten zumindest ist aber mal
für ein für das volkensignal dass die
Ampel sich auch noch mal in irgendeiner
Form irgendwie zusammenraufen kann
zumindest wenn der Kanzler dann mal
einen Machtwort spricht dass man dann
auch mal ein Ergebnis bekommt ja das
werden wir sehen ob die Ampel sich
wirklich zusammenrauft also das glaube
ich jetzt nicht ich glaube dass die
Arbeit in der Ampel eher noch viel viel
ruppiger und
unausgeglichener wird und dass der
Streit und der Zoff eher noch zu nimmt
klar ist hier wurde von oben jetzt
oktroyiert was die Grünen zu tun hat
lässt sich das nicht lange gefallen da
wird ein Rückspiel geben das ist
natürlich erstmal ein ein kleiner Sieg
für die FDP die das ja ungefähr so
wollte was jetzt entschieden wurde für
die Grünen ist es eine Klatsche ihr habt
es ja auch gesagt wir haben zum Beitrag
gesehen so und in der Politik ist es
immer so eine Klatsche lässt man auch
gerade als Alpha Minister der Robert
Habeck ist ungern auf sich sitzen das
heißt da wird es einen Rückspiel geben
und das wird wir werden ein Ping Pong
Erleben von Blockaden auf beiden Seiten
der Koalitionspartner einfach mal FDP
und Grünen das wird sich jetzt
durchziehen und es gibt ist ja auch das
geflügelte Wort von
Müntefering einem großen groß einer
großen großen spd-ikone der gesagt hat
wenn ein Kanzler eine
Richtlinienkompetenz nutzen muss dann
ist die Koalition die er führt
eigentlich am Ende und ehrlicherweise
sehen wir das jetzt zehn Monate nach
Start dieser Ampel nach dem offiziellen
Start muss diese richtigen Kompetenz das
erste Mal vom Kanzler genutzt werden was
nichts anderes beweist da sind die
Gemeinsamkeiten vor allem die Fähigkeit
sich in einem harten Streit zu einigen
aufgebraucht und nicht mehr da das sind
keine guten Aussichten Jan Schäfer
dankeschön für deine Einschätzung
[Musik]